[Music]
what if you had a Google engineer to
support your app development enabling
you to feel better ah you've got you
covered first it should work great on
both square and round devices we wanted
to build a design system that felt at
home on every screen refined typography
geometric iconography bold color I can't
tell you how critical this is for making
a modern looking Android app so keep
calm profile your code and always
remember perf matters we have over a
billion users from over 190 countries
Android marshmallow is harmless and
loveable that could never possibly run
amok in new york and destroy us I'm
going to show you how to extend your
existing music application to work with
Android auto if you've ever spent days
chasing a bug in your code recognize
this do you carry around one phone for
work and another phone for personal use
do you wish you could just carry one
three-two-one rear cassada balloon club
and this one made with Android
[Music]